nous allons faire quelques exercices sur
les fonctions linéaire et sur des
questions de géométrie que vous devez
bien connaître
lisez attentivement les textes sur
l'écran écoutez bien les conseils qu'on
vous donne quand vous ferez des erreurs
vous verrez ce allumé la lampe rouge
mais ne vous découragez pas je vous
aiderai tu es mieux le professeur dit
des choses bien le professeur qui montre
des images où la machine qui te montre
des images et qui te fait décider j'aime
bien les deux façades et plus ça dépend
ce qu'on
ce qu'on nous dise nous passons
maintenant à des problèmes de géométrie
analytique
concernant les fonctionnaires que vous
connaissez regarder le dessin vous y
voyez deux axes de coordonnées et une
droite des dons vous devez chercher
l'équation parmi les quatre qui vous
sont proposées il y as peut-être
plusieurs réponses possibles
c'est en effet la réponse attendue celle
que donne en général les bons élèves
c'est moins impressionnant qu'un
professeur oui mais c'est un jeu de
parler avec cette machine nous sommes
quand tu fais des erreurs qu'est-ce qui
se passe
et le professeur
et alors tu recommences
non il me donne là la solution je dois
la recopier sur mer
pis ça beaucoup plus de patience qu'un
professeur une machine
tant qu'on veut on peut le faire péter
tandis que professeur on n'ose pas lui
demander comment tu pense que ce sera
l'école dans dix ans
[Musique]
et professeurs sûrement des machines
mais est-ce que c'est plus amusant que
professeur niche
[Musique]